we'll do them in the order they appear
on the board which means number two
first which is actually quite gentle
consumer before you can do the quickest
it answer certainly is the easiest nine
s squared tank voice 16 before you tell
me whether that's right or wrong it's
just been written down directly how's
that what knowledge key used to just go
straight there and not like to all of
the inside outside whatever ears are
okay you can see 9 s squared right in
the square of 360 is a square on four
right so your your pizza's here
right now what do you expect when
something is factorized difference of
squares what's the actual result that
you are have learned what and what going
here I'll give you a clue some of the
name Hey - B usually a very fun day and
you remind that's hold that pair of
things together with what the visor was
husband it's a it's a conjugates thank
you very much so is there a square take
16 you test a with it is 9x squared
takeaway 16 lining up with what you
expected sweet thumbs up
good job have a look at the top one six
minus seven X minus three x squared
before we scrutinize it we got the same
answer we go straight the first one the
first one okay a good number thank you
here's now I do any short touch to this
first one are you shocked as it turns
out later on you will know there are
some shortcuts but for now the quickest
way really is just go one across the DOS
do the second one
and I've seen you do all of those just
look at the number of errors how many
terms will you expect at the end after
that extension for right one for each
error but there's only three key ways
what's she done what she don't want the
name of it she collected like totally
okay alright last one now just how do
you look at it we can simplify this a
teeny bit is only one thing that can be
survived here what do you do yeah what
is the other side what you know so this
is 40 on why you do that yes all right
fine this is it could turn violent
yeah I thought I put on on your
condition second just tell me is life
like ER I know we're stretching it but
how many people got their answer you
were there for you not leaves confident
own okay so let's go through this one at
a time it's like yeah if I just above
the one that I returned that Isabelle's
God we actually can go straight there we
can go straight there right yeah how do
you go straight there yeah this is a
perfect square
images okay we're going to try that
technically we get the perfect square
right just like before
this is like the result of formula in
you having you see many times so how's
the space of you able feels good
remember we drew a diagram that shows
it's not just a squared plus edge where
what I'm missing in the do it's the
joint whether they compromise on the
diagram do you remember where do they
come from see is that rectangle and
another rectangle is an ABS Navy so
that's what we're expecting when we
expand okay good now let's just see did
we get it right here 25 what do you
think 49 on white squares what do you
think yeah
and usually those are the bits that are
easiest to get right existed in the
middle this tricky - maybe - maybe he's
a Miss B right so I'm going to do first
multiply them together
5 times 7 over y
scientists in my what's 5 times 7 they
fight over wine and then you double it
right 35 over wine and then you double
it did I do it right is that - it is
right so that should be 71 more - unless
rod 505 is a long time
what do you reckon make somebody think
we will look like you turning so
directions here like so you can say this
is 5 over 1 right which helps you
recognize in the inch 5 over 1
then we've done multiplication before I
know there's addition here but to do to
a B you multiply the 5 and the 7 to 1 to
1 this is this is - maybe it checked out
done is the mix it's easy to get
confused even just when you look at this
mean like people in this letter is that
right I don't looks pretty close right
it is close this is the bit that always
presents people with problems okay so
why are the lines of working entry
because I'll have to do is just pick it
up or would write what do you think are
you happy with announce